ce samedi gérard darmon était l'invité
de l'émission on est en direct sur
france 2 et apparemment l'acteur n'était
pas venu faire que sa promo il en a
profité pour s'en prendre à edwy plenel
co-fondateur de mediapart
quelque chose un peu tartuffe dans votre
discours qui mots qui me gêne un peu de
journalistes qui étaient autour de la
table s'est alors défendu de faire un
devoir de transparence envers les
français citez moi une information
publiée par mediapart depuis bientôt
quinze ans que nous exigions qui n'est
pas été d'intérêt public depuis les
attaques gérard darmon est la cible de
menaces via un tollé de la part des
abonnés surtout de 2 mégas pas alors
êtes vous d'accord avec les propos de
gérard darmon contre le patron de
mediapart
alors déchiré mon avis on va voir
l'extrait parce que le sujet on comprend
rien
mais on dit tout le mal qu'il pensait de
mediapart c'était chaud c'est vous qui a
fait le sujet non pas du tout c'est vous
c'est exiger reconnu ban bien
petit connard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors regardez la pac déjà je suis un
peu déçu parce que c'est un homme au
départ quand tu es contre médiapart a
été a été fondée qui était c'était
plutôt encourageant ce détient voilà une
espèce de chevalier blanc comme ça qui
va qui va
qui va débusquer des dossiers etc alors
vous savez tout vous savez tout et rien
d'autre je trouve vous alerter les gens
comme si c'était quelque chose alors il
faut lui il faut le prendre au sérieux
mais je ne sais pas je n'aime pas mais
je je trouve que les méthodes ne sont
pas très
très très efficace il ya quelque chose
d'un peu tartus dans votre discours qui
me gêne un peu
non non non oui oui oui oui eux gérard
lalouette un ami ben moi aussi un ami
oui
[Applaudissements]
on
va revoir la question êtes vous d'accord
librement autre patron de médiapart on
va prendre mais oui à d'abord je vais
prendre le oui de mathieu tient matin
mais c'est maintenant entendre sa voix
la wii pour l'instant on n'a entendu que
son slip
et non ah bah non mais t'es sur
[Rires]
un ami mais si on donne le problème
c'est que mediapart aujourd'hui devenue
politisée c'est ça le souci mais en vrai
de vrai à la base c'est quand même
derrière canard enchaîné c'est quand
même ceux qui ont sorti quand même des
enquêtes vraiment vraiment approfondi
que je trouve quand même top c'est à
dire le cas usa que c'était c'est s
étaient eux bien comme ça donc si tu
veux je chante ken que c'était des vrais
vraiment canal malheureusement à du pnl
a pris melon est malheureusement attendu
si médiatisé et malheureusement
aujourd'hui c'est plus tellement c'est
plus tellement
bon voilà c'est plus tellement les gens
minces
l'attak de darmon elles portent elles
portent essentiellement non pas 30 ans
sur le travail de mediapart que sur la
personnalité d'edwy plenel qui se
présente plus comme un procureur de
celui qui donne les bons points les
mauvais points bruxelles le journalisme
à lui tout seul et c'est en ça que
c'était la taille
il parle aussi des méthodes de médiapart
hélas que décrivent et cyril et quelques
instants pardon mais c'est dégueulasse
faire croire et c'est pouvoir être la
ligue 1 de participer à un film une
interview reeves encore que c'est un
autre sujet pardon et je me changeais
imputant à la police la conversation
parce que j'étais sympa avec eux en plus
non mais je suis simple tu plutôt sympa
avec eux je leur dis oui avec plaisir
tout ça mais après j'ai pas bu et après
voilà là on a on l'a pas fait parce que
on s'est renseigné on a su que c'était
pour faire ça briaud va donc c'est vrai
que ces voix là mais y'en a marre de ces
médias qui ont la carte qui peuvent tout
se permettre nous citer pmp on faisait
ça on se ferait défoncé ça ferait un
scandale et voilà c'est pas parce que
c'est mediapart ou tel ou tel média
entre guillemets sérieux qui peuvent
tout se permettre journalistique mans
donc je comprends ce qu'a dit oui
madame ya même si quelque chose gérard
darmon il est comme vous il défend ses
amis parce que il est très ami avec eric
dupond-moretti savait que mad mediapart
année-là tacchella et
le fait très souvent donc il a parlé
aussi avec son coeur moi j'ai trouvé que
c'était très mesuré il l'a défoncé mais
en douceur j'ai adoré
sans évoquer des médecins façon moi
j'aime tout ce que fait marc darmon
s'est
vraiment mais franchement c'est ce que
je dis là c'est veulent pas ou alors
géraldine vide alors moi j'adore gérard
darmon puis s'il est né le 29 février
comme moi et je suis avec les moines
d'accord elle voulait qu'on entend que
ce soit
si je suis malhonnête intellectuellement
je dis que je suis d'accord avec lui
parce que l'accord que je suis je suis
d'accord avec lui d'un point de vue
idéologique
je suis complètement d'accord avec lui
après moi je trouve qu'il a un peu raté
son coup d'abord un s'attaquer
physiquement à quelqu'un en dix ans qui
tremblaient je trouve que c'est
maladroit parce qu'on a droit de
trembler parce qu'on peut avoir une
maladie neurologique on peut avoir un
parkinson tremblay non mais je trouve
que ça ne se fait pas je trouve que
c'est hors sujet et ensuite
idéologiquement maintenant quand il divo
en gros vous avez rien sortir tout ça et
il lui dit mais qu'est ce que j'ai fait
ce que j'ai pas sortis ou qu'est-ce que
j'ai sorti qu en fait il n'a rien dit il
n'a rien pu dire zéro soit il le fait
vraiment il veut se faire plein elle il
y va et à ce moment là il extermine soi
mais là ils étaient entre 2 et pardon
mais moi je suis pas censé savoir qu'il
est copain avec dupont moretti parce que
je spectatrice et à ce moment là c'est
un peu un brave et joke était que un peu
entre lui s'il est dit ouais ok vous
avez sorti sarkozy qu'à use and men
alamo pas alors les controverses sur how
ça ok monsieur plenel mais en revanche
vous avez aussi été moyens quand vous
étiez au monde par rapport à baudis par
rapport à d'autres que vous avez été
bizarre avec tariq ramadan aussi wii ou
avec que les attentats avec les frères
kwasi là moi je veux bien l'entendre
darmon ah oui les wem et celui des trois
cols à oui oui mais du coup la jetterait
il a parlé beaucoup d'anti sémitisme
edwy plenel samedi soir savez quand on
parle un peu trop de quelque chose c'est
que il ya un souci meilleure amie quand
même un magazine mois là elle et le
pousser dans ses retranchements et je
trouve qu'il a été à ce moment-là trop
tendre oui valérie qu on peut lui
rappeler l'article qu'il avait fait sur
les militants de l'organisation
palestine et septembre un soir on
absolument rio où il s'était fait
l'effort se trouve à féliciter mon big
eyes l'avenir il avait dit qu'on pouvait
comprendre que con qu'on tue des
athlètes israël mais elle aurait dû dire
ça mais moi la darmon mais ça est vrai
vu que certains soirs il a parlé
beaucoup d' antisémite c'est ce qu'il
avait mis en avant la wii
oui mais je suis sûr mais benjamin moi
je frime moi je met dans le même panier
que et élise lucet je trouve que ces
enquêtes sont souvent
monette les méthodes de mediapart
excusez moi je rejoins complètement
guillot match est ce que tu es d'accord
exemple parce que je
voulais dire j'étais d'accord avec toi
oui moi je trouve que l'on mette un
effectif qui vont ses clés voilà c'est
un peu des méthodes voilà c'est toujours
un peu des deux voyous
ils sortent évidemment ils sortent
évidemment de gros à faire il m'en fais
à mes marques parfois des méthodes de
voyou et non pas parce que basique
typiquement de demander une interview
pour un sujet qui n'est pas celui qu'on
va traiter de de changer d'identité de
fin de vie du voyage avec les yeux
de tous ouais bah oui bien sûr donc moi
je prouve que ces méthodes là sont pas
voilà sont pas tellement répété après il
fait son travail il a fait de très beau
dossier et je trouve que maintenant
c'est toujours un peu dans nos veines
nous savons que c'est pareil kelly non
je n'ai pas d'avis mois
wii wii fit moi je trouve que c'est
hypocrite de la part de gérard darel
voilà c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu déjà eu
des couilles jardin désolé mais j'aurais
bien aimé qu'on dit mais de l'adisq leur
temps
voilà ma fille tu veux mais je m'en veux
aussi finir bon alors ce qui se passe
c'est que bien sûr que plenel et parfois
insupportable parce qu'il prétend
détenir la vérité du monde la vérité
journalistique
souvent c'est vrai qu'il a les bons
documents pour faire ces articles mais
parfois il est insupportable mais
néanmoins gérard damman il doit dire
tout de suite moi je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous je ne vous aime pas
parce que vous avez attaqué mon ami
monsieur dupont moretti tout de suite
non mais faut il le dire c'est le régime
sacha tout à fait d'accord pas du tout
il donnait de lui donner son avis voilà
c'est la raison série celle des 2,6
franchement
ça passe ou ça rien à voir ici je vais
parce qu'ils n'aiment pas ils n'aiment
pas leur seul média médiapart je pense
que vous êtes à côté de la plaque accusé
d'antisémitisme aussi existent
géraldine a raison bien sûr il ya tout
le personnel après et edwy plenel de
médiapart il venait aussi vendre son
film et j'ai pas si vous avez vu je
pense qu'il est un des meilleurs et
parce que leur on a fait très peu sur le
film et qui est venu à 0 rien excellent
contre avec edwy plenel il a été
excellent lors ok c'est excellent mais
les yeux c'était un rituel bazar mais
quand même qu'on aime ou pas les deux
ans un moment de télé edwy plenel
laurent ruquier c'est un moment de télé
je suis désolé et je trouvais voilà ça
fait du bien de voir ça à la télé moi je
suis désolé voilà maintenant qu'on aime
laurent ruquier qu'on ne les aime pas
tous les deux contre un des deux c'est
ça qu'on veut voir la laitue direct
c'est comme tout à l'heure donc en deux
voilà c'est comme ça le battu de longs
et moi ce que
je rejoins pas benjamin je crois que
c'était un cinquième accusé me suis pas
sûr qu'ils aient les mêmes les mauvaises
manières font de bons journalistes je
pense qu'il n'ya il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas de mauvaises manies seule chose qui
compte c'est le résultat qui sait où la
moue la manière dont ces prix même avec
vous cyril à poser la mauvaise question
ce qui compte c'est d'avoir la bonne
réponse et je pense qu'effectivement
pardon il n'y a pas de journalistes mais
qui compte
effectivement gerald avant un problème
c'est que là il s'est pas défendu du
travail début panel il s'est défendu de
l'homme qui l'aimé pas parce qu'il
attaque ses potes donc c'était un bon
moment de télé médard m'en étais pas
très honnête j dacquois a que pour sa
part cette fois leur ont valu à john
yapp est raisonnée mais parce qu'encore
une fois il s'en prend à edwy plenel
mais pas sur son travail sans point
mexique
n'a pas son travail ces nuages et il ya
plein de trucs qu'il ya pas de truc qui
déplaisent acharnement chez lui plaît ne
voit pas les rings géraldine la diva oui
posé il ya eu à reprocher une forme de
tartufferie bah oui dont il a eu
l'exemple typiquement sur le plateau
quand il a reproché à retiers de
d'ouvrir l'interview avec balkany a
lui-même avait faire dossier sur malkani
visant à vous reprocher aux autres ce
que vous faites vous de ce qu'on a
encore les chômage dans cette émission
wes brown était intervenu alors regardez
alors 46 et 50 50 je vous dis c'est un
peu comme si ça qu'est foule a voulu ici
on donne la parole quand le dis à tout
le monde et pascal et viala turner nous
incitons
on est content que médiapart il ya même
des enfants comme sarkozy entendu vous
georges tron toutes ces affaires là les
le ciment le ciment lafarge hôpital qui
a eu avec moi j'étais content quand même
qu'on m'a dit que kalisa qui faisaient
le coup droit dans les yeux il nous a
dit que c'est pas vrai ben c'est
médiapart qui a sorti ça quand tu
entends quand monsieur blanc caire il
prend une photo dans son bureau et que
médiapart dit non alors pas dans son
bureau du genre qu'il est là il a il est
là il y en a parlé de ça moi je suis
content maintenant qu'ils font ça
mediapart après que c'est bien que
gérard darmon ils soient pas contents
ils seraient de médias
si les fonds toxiques et voilà
[Applaudissements]